tile MCN is back along with my laptop um
I won't preserve this guy I'll show some
respect
I'll play some kind of write and play a
solid opening
NIMS Oh people thinking early in the
game okay let's play d5 have a London
I enjoy playing against the London
things I enjoyed for both sides see
three usually people play e3 not sure if
it makes a difference it does allow the
media Queen b6
some funny line I just calculated Queen
b6 Queen B 3 C 4 Queen c2 Bishop f5
Queen take f5 Queen take b2 Queen CH
checkmate
that would be devastating let's play
next C 6 I just want to transpose into
this main line with with Queen b6 and
this is known to be I think it's known
to be good for black at least equalizing
this is a line I recommend against
London anyone who's looking for a line
against the London if you can reach this
position it's already very pleasant
sometimes White has ways to
circumnavigate but it is usually pretty
pleasant for black
um III these replayable usually leads to
a slower or positional game I'm gonna
play Bishop at five in the past I've
taken but now I just want to build up
pressure
now I guess it's not too often to
calculate mates so curly
why nuances are important
like Queen d6 was an idea Bishop d3 I
have two options I have this and I have
this
I can play this I want to
but I'm not sure in 94 9h for
kind of got kicked around
I'm just going to be solid I just want
to play e6 complete developments
that he's played b3 gives me some some
queenside play
um potentially in the future given that
I can I can build a pressure against
this either the c3 pawn or the c3 square
I also have the open each file now could
be used for something maybe I'll play
nature 5 soon
sort of you six
do I have a leech a study on this not
this specific line I gave a st. Louis
Chess Club lecture on black winning
against one d4 and I go over some games
she'd go over a lot of my games
and some famous games or black just
crushes in London
I went over some leggings and Queens
gambit declined as well
q1
in 95
an idea to play at some point
I could take but then he takes back
they're probably just favorites in
yes 9h five comes with a threat because
he won't let me he doesn't want me to
take on f4 and get the structure so 9h
five you could play Bishop g5 mf6
the ship h4g five trades man bishop
lands on d6
and if the media push of g3 I take and
Bishop d6
if he plays efore I take
looks fine for black
any time he plays e4 in the position
opens up I'll be the only player with a
bishop
assuming I'm forcing the trade
and I don't want to castle-like too
early I don't want to commit my king
especially because my rook is a quite
often very happy on each AIDS
geom Cola which I've never heard of that
name um I I will admit I have not looked
at too many too many things on chasuble
I've wanted to it's on my to-do list but
just haven't gotten around to it
I don't really when it comes to like
learning openings are learning new
openings I don't really use books or
other sorts of like online like chasuble
things I do a lot of preparation just
using databases
my franchisee says lose not sure what
that's referring to
hello two more people in the chats
[Music]
well the line I calculated is exactly
what Anja stood against messy Marvin
ouch uh Franco Loeb a London or Queens
gambit
I don't want to tell people what to do
but London just such a huge London fan
and it's easier to learn if you play
Queen's Gambit you have to be prepared
for like ruin felled and slaw semi slob
Queens gambit accepted London you just
play the London so this guy's allowing
this trade
actually a lot of trades can happen
tick-tick-tick
I think you would have to take on c6 I
took here he takes back and we'll get
some positional position or it'll have
probably some weakness on d4 and I'll
have a bishop
their option is to take the night's
let's take the bishop
just relying on intuition here
expecting Knight takes c6
and I think I'll take with pawn
one thing that could happen like tick
tick I could hit play immediately c5f
tick tick I keep initiative
also have initiative with Bishop b4
there's a few options to consider
there's a drawback with playing c-56
five you could play Knight c3
ideas of both night a for as well as
night 85 it can be really annoying
can also play Bishop d6 with tempo
provoke some g3
you
and you have options
a bishop before looks most traps but
should be for Ricky too
let's see five and he plays a three
you
that's another idea like Bishop d6 if he
plays g3 I put my rook
alright someday like gopher this idea of
doubling up on the H file
each too would be a bigger targets
you
and you want to play c5 it just doesn't
seem to be working
mmm okay Bishop d6 g3 c5
Knight c3 well if I just take
it takes on d5 I play Quincy five
this is my trapped might look straps
there his Queen f3
well then just Castle kingside mind
still trapped
you
okay let's do that looks simple
you
and I see three is not the easiest movie
to find unless he's watching the stream
but
if okay let's I'm predicting g3 c5 if he
doesn't play Knight c3 I think it's very
easy for black when he pretty much has
to take I take there's no time to take
on d5 I don't think any time I can just
Castle and be safe 2x I sparks below a
long time no see
questions from the chats
nanny crow hoping to crush me
they're against John Bartholomew
you're not using books how are you
determining moves are somatic often hear
you talk about themes
yeah I mean
ever opening you play it helps to see a
large number of high level games in that
opening and that's one of the main ways
like learn openings just seeing how
Gratton asters play them and then kind
of building building a repertoire around
high level games and also using the
engine to like seeing the recurring
ideas so I already did most of the
calculation it's going to double check
I'm not missing anything
like c3
Big D 495 Quincy 5.03 castle
do it
if he takes on c5 I take back with
bishop
Vala 57 from Quebec welcome you Canadian
viewers today
this opening the goal is
control d5
um
when t5 is usually controlled by black
but maybe it's more relevant in some
other lines
but yeah using databases is a huge
component not only being able to find
games but seeing what the most common
moves are and then seeing how they score
how often they're played searching for
moves which are rare but so strong
um speaking of openings X ice sparks oh
asking me about the London series before
I get to that X ice sparks I did a
stream the other day thank you Miss
Miyagi for the follow I did a stream the
other day building a leach a study of
London against Kings Indian cuz i think
i think those excise sparks who messaged
me about that so it was a few days ago i
can send you the link if you need it
well okay he's he's sort of attacking d5
I don't think it's a threat though
because f2 is also
order pressured
calculating sums funny line like Bishop
take f2 and then rub take h2 but it
doesn't work because Queen take b6 wait
a minute am I just trapping the rook
thus winning material fish a d4 no
Knight c3 okay
wait Bishop d4 Knight c3 rook c8 you can
take on d5
drink elope thanks for the follow
maybe I play rook c8 first preventing
Knight c3 also just putting a rook on
the only open file Russell and thanks
for the follow so many following people
Brooksie it if he plays Knight c3 I went
up on with Bishop take F to work see if
he takes on d5 it's just terrible for
him rook c8 92 probably is likely
then Bishop before could be played
quint 85 i would have worked e AIDS
okay I'm gonna play Rick see it I don't
want to take too much time
like there's gonna be a force to win
here it's just about improving the
pieces but I'm very happy relatively
open position my bishop is active
ever nursey thanks for the follow
also my pawn structure is better
and there's a variety of different plans
here whether I want to castle whether I
want to sort of try and make use of
h-file
looking at ideas like 92 bishop before
let's say they rook 81 and then rook C
to apply pressure
Oh to answer excise marks question the
London series will be released sometime
in July and I don't know the exact dates
but I will keep people posted
Russell and welcome to the chat miss me
ugly with it with the emote
campus ringling appreciating but I I
share all my secrets with my thought
process summer thanks for the follow
new subs get a sneak preview
unfortunately probably not because I'm
not the one releasing the course I'm
doing it through a company so
but I will have like a my I will do like
uh some free like webinars or like just
extra content that will be maybe it will
be exclusive to subs but I'll see I'm
brainstorming ways to so get people
excited when the time hits closer okay
he plays my d2 I was expected
can I take on f2 this is a forcing line
big tick take four tickets to he has to
play King III to defend the night and
then I play looks fun
I could play rook c3
kingi for only move I can't take the
night cuz my rook is this attacked but I
could take out in g3 and then he Forks
me and he's probably winning that
position
what's going on bishop take F -
sometimes annoying thing about about
schemes like this is there's no way he
he was counting all this line but now
it's up to me to see if it works
he didn't have to he didn't offend any I
think she's probably calculating this I
don't think it works Bishop taking off -
Queen take up to take take richtig H -
King III there's this deform move
thinking G 3
rooks III he takes
you
thinking of it thing is if it works I
just it's worth devoting the time to
think about it but if it doesn't work
it's sometimes a waste of energy
no show take F - any ideas that I'm
missing
take-take-take I've worked see too but
that doesn't work
I don't think this works I should take
f2 I mean if it maybe I can make it work
in like where I went a bunch of pawns
King III
and then maybe rook
I don't think it's worth going for that
even if I'm winning pawns at least still
gonna have that night
so time to consider other moves Bishop
before was one of the main
considerations realizing if I put Bishop
before you play rook c1
could be annoying because I'm if I take
it takes I take on details Roxy a check
and probably want to keep my Bishop on
c5
you
what else to do
Wien before ISM of dachshund night his
mites pretty restricted here my pawn is
controlling squares my plane I have
flown at some points
so now I'm thinking bishop before
does exert pressure let's imagine he
plays some move like rook AC one and I
just castle in blocks better in these
like these quieter lines
and if I play here
just to reiterate I think I mentioned
this between 285 I would have this rook
ta move
that would be winning
okay let's play Bishop before I'm
accepting that I'm not going to get any
like any
tactics at work on the h-file so it
makes sense to castle and just focus
focus more towards the center focus on
the file which I control
more people in the chat the ice happy
Friday
what company uh I chest net they do a
number of online courses they came out
recently one with one Shanklin did they
work with like a lot of a lot of strong
players stronger players in me produced
courses so it's the first time working
with them so hopefully it turns out well
I says just do it
I don't know what it's refers to
a sensible business plan would be to
build up a strong base of followers and
then move on to building base of subs
I'm still at the stage where I just want
to give value to people I'm not too
concerned with my sub-base
because that will come if I if I keep
doing what I'm doing I'm also looking
for a feedback to like if people want to
see specific types of streams the link
Kyah official thank you for the follow
is there background noise ie okay I'm
using a new mic I forgot to ask that but
I forgot to ask if the audio is okay but
this is my mic it's much smaller than my
other mic if there's background noise I
can up the filter
I got the smaller mic because I'll be
I'll be traveling I didn't want to take
my gigantic one around with me
that's a cardioid
filter
I'll play the mic is great okay
hopefully the background noise isn't too
distracting if it is I'll play around
with the filters later let's focus rook
ad one it's a move
rooks see two looks appealing
I can castle and just be happy but
sometimes I would like more rook situ
you could potentially take on d5
you
you know this castle I'm threatening
rook situ
kind of stuck because Knights pinned
yeah let's just castle this rook will be
more valuable in helping control the C
file
Gabriel says if
using OBS you can help me with the
configurations well probably after this
game um let me okay I'm just going to
view the stream from my phone and I'll
see how it sounds
hey I broke 18 18 hundred followers
thank you people
Oh
probably after this game
so the filter appears to be working but
whenever I talk it you get like the
it sounds weird
well I could do I could try and clip on
like it's small enough to like clip on
to like a jacket or something so I might
play around with that a bit later a few
people so far have mentioned this idea
rooks III which is very possible
um I just don't know if it has any
long-term I guess it hits the Queen and
then ideas rook rook c8
more interested in playing Brooksie to
hitting the night in this pawn f2 is a
target there's a lot of juicy targets on
the second drink and even though it's
equal material and seems like White has
everything defended the position could
fall apart pretty quickly for whites
you
you
yeah I I know what Arielle is talking
about it's because my fan is on letting
the computer fan and the mic is so close
to the computer that it's picking up the
noise and the family's so rookie to is
one of the moves I was considering for
white and my initial thought was Queen D
for it to pin the the knight to the work
I'm d1
so if I play Brooksie to hear he plays a
night f1 hides and tries to be safe
that's a line work see - neither for
milk fc8
I mean maybe here see three makes sense
Brooksie three
hitting the Queen he plays here then I
probably play Roxy to
rooks III Queen G - then maybe I can
start building up against tonight
you
yeah if I can improve with tempo like
why not
there's no tricks rights
counter-attacks are these are going to
have to make some concession here if
queen g2 then
the threat of the idea of rook d3 in
Queen d4 is I think it should be winning
material
the pin is the pin is just too strong
three and winning at least upon
the odds are my opponent is listening to
the stream I'm aware of that
I usually assume my opponent is watching
the stream which I'm okay with if I play
good enough I should be able to win even
if my opponent is hearing my thoughts
miss it miss Miyagi with the one bit
thanks miss Miyagi
you
there are situations where I think
quietly because I don't want my my
opponents listening to some like key
calculations but situation like this I
mean he knows rook c3 and rook c2 are
coming and there's really nothing he can
do to stop it
whoa what is going on oh that was me
doing the audio test means they'll be
quick time
people could have people probably heard
that accidentally played the audio file
his testing earlier
I wonder
I'm pretty sure my computer volume is
being shared
like when the move is made then people
hear that and move I would think
Brooksie to
better
d4 of take III these are all candidate
moves but rook c2 looks strongest
Knight c4 is protected by a
that is tax if I have fun so
I don't think that's a great move
okay now I'm attacking the knight
attacking the pawn I'm expecting
something like rookie 2 or night f1
I'll take the pawn probably bring the
bishop back to c5
I should not allow one bit
I don't think I'm being called a
homeless person I'm just
I guess I'm I'm difficult one bit or
worth more than a bit
appreciate one bits I mean it's going to
contribute to some parking meter
okay or all just invested in like crypto
and it'll be worth like
probably be worth less in sometime rook
to e3
Kirk to k2
is a free pond
the great thing is both of his rooks are
tied down and they're both really not
doing that much and I just want to play
rook c8 rook c2 next 20 bits from this
miyagi so generous
now I'm I don't think I can be
classified as a homeless person anymore
unless is that still insulting I'm not
insulted
I do take Bitcoin donations I enabled
whatever the thing is in stream labs so
I it takes like Bitcoin like coin
theorem
but I've yet to receive any crypto from
streaming at least okay
you wants to attack h5 I think I can
just ignore it calculate rook c8 h5 r XE
2
take take
we need five and then I made him my f2
it's nice
you
are you a practical player
her best move I understand that question
um it's he's essentially asking do I
play
um the best way do I put all the effort
in trying to find the best one possible
or do I just play some move that gets
the job done
on the time control in rapid or blood
schemes or even these sort of classical
games you have to be practical but in
longer games I'm always striving to play
the best move
and sometimes being practical is playing
the best move especially at the higher
levels
see -
our coordinating miss Miyagi with 50
bits so generous
definitely no longer homeless just need
to to keep the bits coming to buy a home
or the pond yeah ignoring ponds are the
best strategy
not worth in USD Oh crypto net worth was
about to say your total net worth that
would be bad since November 2017 oh yeah
cuz November was like the peak or
January was a peak and then
things happened
I just say playing practical is the best
move I mean sometimes the the most
practical decision overlaps with playing
the best move but there are differences
like you could draw a Venn diagram of
moves and sometimes the the intersection
of practical moves and best move I don't
know this is getting too theoretical
like to give an example that's okay for
example let's say this position let's
imagine for some reason Bishop take F to
was working for some tactical reason
where I would have to calculate 10 moves
deep it might not be the most practical
decision because it's risky I could miss
calculate I could spend a lot of time
and get low on time 23 more bits from
Miss Miyagi thank you Miss Miyagi so the
practical move here was uh was either to
castle or play Bishop before we can go
back and take a look at that moment
oh I forgot to calculate this line
I can't ignore his stuff too much
like rook take G two ticks on f7 I just
play King f8 simple enough
to attack
- as hing if anyone is counter-attacking
it's me okay take off -
the very least I'll be on the bishop
king of it
you
I also want to clarify that I'm not
playing this tournament an attempt to
get first place
because I've done that before and it's
just it needs to lower quality chests
I'm just playing this tournament to try
and have some instructive games I'm
probably not going to play the full
tournament I I put something in my
schedule I'm gonna play this for two or
three hours hopefully not more I said
more I might be sorry
armed with 50 bits so many generous
people
why would I say that it's always true or
always be a percentile FN diagram yeah
there's a weird question
you
I don't know what he's referring to what
I said that he's asking why I said it
hopefully everything I said made sense
if it didn't I'm sorry
miss Miyagi with the purple badge yeah
the more bits you throw the more
colorful your your badge gets I think
Brooksie and i did not calculate a rook
rook c1 with a threaded rook c8 is a
little bit concerning I mean at the very
least I can trade Queens and just be
completely winning let's just do that
this should prompt some kind of
resignation he'll give a few checks
or nuts chess bus what is your
for determining strengths and weaknesses
of your students yeah game reviews I
also like to play my students and not
only like playful games I like to see
how they play out some types of
positions because then when I'm actively
playing my students and then like
involved with the game it's just much
more easy to identify what areas they
need to work on whether it's tactical
issues or or time management
decision-making
there should be some kind of force mates
her gift to his mates okay that was nice
backpack Apple was great it was a 24
hour turnaround originally they were
gonna ship it and was gonna be three to
five days so like here back and then I
told them I'm leaving the country on
Tuesday and the guy was like super super
accommodating so my Mac is back we can
go over that game real quick analysis
board anyone watching who doesn't know
what to play against the London okay
let's disabled analysis for the moment
yeah anyone who doesn't know what to
play against in London I highly
recommend this line the main line here
is Queen from three and then fish about
five and I gave a lecture on this line
the best move here I think is Knight h5
and there's some really nice game with
Raja Mika so anyway well I was curious
about this line Queen b6 immediately
there's a line I calculated was similar
Bishop f5 would be a terrible move here
because Queen take a five Queen take b2
and then black its meted so maybe I
could play knight c6 here and maybe it
would transpose but maybe not like BB 2
because White has before
for
so looks playable anyway let's go
forward with the game had some position
I was happy with this 9h five move to
remove the bishop as we saw how this
play the role later in the game where I
just control the dark squares and the
dark squared Bishop was just so
effective yeah I was hesitant to play c5
because of Knight c3 I mean like kind of
looks scary but the rationale was after
take take here the night is just trapped
just in the center and if you place coin
out three I just Castle
I think the Knights still trapped
so he took which is really the only
other option and then this is where I
wanted to take on f2 but I didn't see
anything
some forcing line like the king is
almost made that if I have a pawn on e5
it would be made in one but it just
doesn't work out
if I could get away with taking on g3
maybe I would go for the sign just for
fun
problem was rook take G 3 9 f 1 so
again continued I think it was pretty
straightforward just getting the pieces
active and finding harmony
what about sack on d4 uh what sack on d4
I'm not sure I'm not sure at what moment
you're referring to
bowling kaya official
and then Oh after Bishop take f2 oh yeah
that line I don't think this did
anything because he has King D 3
I would try and like the
obviously the goal is to remove the king
from defending the Knights but to do
that I have to put my rook on c3 he
takes my rook is attacked
and I didn't see anything here exercise
sparks with Sunline I was looking at 20
- Ricky -
you
so 22 rookie to Ortega to o'night c4 ah
I see but then queen a6
you
I didn't see this idea with night C for
hitting the Queen in the rough I think
this is OK for luck some nights now
attacked and things are getting traded
real quick I'll see if I miss anything
like too drastic do they have
while did did this line work after 92
this should take F - it's just better
for whites okay
what were my mistakes
people can't see this if i zoom in now
people can see this I made two mistakes
and uh yeah two mistakes one in accuracy
so if I click on this go back
miss Jake rooked 82 is a mistake okay
it's still winning
Rick take t2 is it's one of these
practical decisions Bishop takes you to
so that's move rotate t2 is just way
more practical and then later we take f2
is a mistake
yeah I didn't want to mess with Brooke
Brooke take t3 rook CDA check it's
another one of these practical things or
he starts checking me like king take a
seven queen not five not worth the
energy to calculate because King e7
that's only moved to survive there's no
way I would do this and then Queenie a
check in f6 this is okay this is how you
catch computer cheaters those computer
cheaters will go for a line like this as
black there is some case actually
recently in in Norway
whereas some cheater was caught and one
of his games like he went for it one
line like this where his King like walks
all the way up the board and it's all
calculated out there wasn't like no
reason to ever go for this anyway hope
people enjoy that I will probably put
this on YouTube